inside of every computer is a web of
components that work together quite
miraculously to
spit counter-strike out onto your
monitor some of them help you multitask
while others do a bit of everything that
said there is one key piece if you're
trying to game one golden component at
the heart of every pc that prevents your
games from
well making you nauseous in fact this
one thing can make or break an entire
gaming rig
your graphics card they are the most
sought after piece of hardware in the pc
gaming world and regardless of how
clouded certain graphics cards may be
some people
myself included don't even understand
how they work so
today we are going to break down
what exactly a gpu does when you hop
into a server how it actually works and
what is perhaps the most ever burning
question
does having a good graphics card
actually help you play better
[Applause]
for this week's episode we've decided to
team up with the crew over at amd once
again but this time we're gonna break
down what exactly it is that a graphics
card does so what is a gpu well first
off it's an acronym
which is about all i know about gpus gpu
stands for graphics processing unit
scratch that that's all i know about
gpus in your pc while your central
processing unit or cpu is busy
performing calculations for various
programs your gpu is working to render
3d images to your monitor now both of
them sit on the motherboard but they're
actually very different components at
its core the simplest way to describe
what a graphics card does for your
computer is that it renders graphics and
puts them on your monitor
i know thanks dimitri
super helpful but where did that all
begin like these things have been around
for decades now and let me tell you that
4 000 card you're looking at on amazon
used to look a lot different well to
help answer this question i brought in
my boy darren from amd to help us out
consumer graphics have been around since
the mid 70s in things like the first
atari console which had dedicated
graphics inside
but it was probably really in the early
80s early to mid 80s that the first
commercial graphics cards were brought
into the market they were color graphics
adapters and their only job was really
to
emulate color and some of the early pc
monitors at the time more on the
business side but it wasn't until
1985 that operating systems like windows
became the norm and video cards started
to be more accessible to the average
consumer in 1987 the ibm
8514 was released and basically became
the single most popular graphics card in
the market but it wasn't exactly a
graphics card like we know today you see
the ibm 8514 was more of a display
adapter that supported the
1024x768 resolution that many of those
boomer crt monitors had and not long
after canadian company ati technologies
released their ati wonder series cards
which allowed for dual monitor setups
can you imagine these gangsters back in
the late 80s running dual monitor setups
and you're still not this was a pretty
big deal at the time but in the early
1990s application programming interfaces
like opengl and microsoft directx
allowed developers to write code for
nearly any type of graphics adapter you
see in the 90s
graphics card production really hit the
ground running in the early 90s is when
we saw the first graphics cards come
into the market that were capable of 2d
acceleration
but then everything changed more in the
mid 90s in 1995 we saw the first
graphics cards come into the market
which were capable
of not only 2d acceleration but also 3d
and video acceleration so on our side
the ati rage 3d was the first 3d
accelerated card that we produced this
was essentially the starting point for
3d support in graphics cards gpus like
the s3 verge and the 3d fx voodoo
dominated the market in the mid 90s
but when nvidia released the geforce 256
in 1999
that's when advances in gpu technology
really stepped up over the next decade
nvidia and ati were the two main
competitors on the market and in 2006
ati was acquired by amd since then
geforce and radeon cards that you
probably recognize have been the best
option available for gamers now we've
talked a lot about the history of gpus
but cpu integrated graphics have come a
long way which has probably caused a lot
of you to wonder
why is it that you can't just buy a
really good cpu and have that do
everything and what it comes down to is
the amount of cores the average modern
cpu has about eight cores
while gpus have anywhere from a thousand
to four thousand now this might sound
like a lot but each individual core on a
cpu is much more powerful this doesn't
mean that the cores on a cpu are best
used for processing graphics however at
a very high level cpus are designed to
be versatile but ultimately they need to
run through a series of tasks incredibly
fast the gpu's role is different it's
it's really designed to break down
really complex instructions into
thousands or even millions of parallel
tasks so for example in a game you're
rendering shapes lighting textures
all of this has to be done
simultaneously so it all has to be
broken down and done in parallel
in other words the graphics processor
has always been built around a more
parallel processing approach and as a
result it requires a much larger number
of course so the cpu is basically the
brain of your computer sending
instructions to all the rest of the
components while the gpu pumps images
and graphics to your display graphics
cards are pretty much a requirement for
rendering 3d worlds in video games
especially in modern games where
lighting and shadow effects have become
much more realistic but there is one key
component to a graphics card that helps
bolster its performance compared to
rendering from a cpu
and that's vram now you've likely heard
of ram before it's the third or fourth
best half punk album
i'm kidding it's memory stored directly
on your computer's motherboard random
access memory also known as ram is very
fast short-term memory which is used to
store data that is regularly used by
your computer ram helps with
multitasking so when you're opening your
content google chrome tab then it'll be
there to help carry the load plenty of
people commonly mistake their computer's
memory for storage but the latter is
only reserved for hard drives and
solid-state drives which are used to
store long-term memory in this day and
age most computers have 8 to 16
gigabytes of ram depending on the user's
needs
and when colton is editing these heater
videos
trust me
he needs ram so just like normal ram
vram is used to store short-term memory
the thing is it's much more accessible
to your graphics card because it's
built into the damn thing so video ram's
dedicated graphics memory um and
it's allocated for the operations of
your graphic card
it's very similar almost identical to
the way that your system memory works
with your cpu so video ram is used to
store and cue the data and assets that
the gpu needs to process all those
visual assets gets stored in the
graphics memory before it gets rendered
to your screen some information in
certain games needs to be accessed
regularly so it's stored in your
graphics card's vram and sent to the gpu
so when you load up mirage for the
[ __ ] millionth time your computer
loads the map's data into your gpu
memory so it already knows what to
expect because your graphics card
already has bits and pieces of it stored
in its vram so in esports gpus are
pretty important plenty of titles like
cs go valorant and even league of
legends are all heavily cpu bound but
they still need graphics cards to run
well fundamentally it's not different
from playing any other game it's really
about rendering the game visuals from an
esports perspective specifically the
purpose of the gpu i would say is also
to run your game as fast and smoothly as
possible you really want those fast
frame rates sure you can maybe squeeze
out a couple of extra frames if you play
with the absolute lowest possible
settings using integrated graphics
but you don't want to play competitive
shooter or moba if it looks like a
slideshow you know typically we tend to
see a lot of esports titles that throw a
lot of calculations at the cpu where
the graphics rendering isn't as taxing
titles that are are more
taxing on the gpu side maybe a little
bit more cpu centric they're much more
common in single-player games like rpgs
real-time strategy games so where
players are really cranking up their
settings and resolution where the game
developers
trying to create a really immersive
experience there's also some competitive
titles though that you know you can see
some gpu bottlenecks on they would be
games like rainbow six siege or pub g as
well which are a little bit more taxing
on the gpu side versus the the cpu side
in a title like rainbow six siege there
are actually certain settings you're
going to want to keep on if you plan on
competing at the highest level turning
shadows or lod down in siege for
instance will cause you to lose the
shadows entirely and the hitboxes will
start looking all square and pixelated
if you're playing a game at the highest
level of competition or plan to then you
want it to run smoothly most pro players
run these games in excess of 200 frames
per second to avoid any sort of screen
tearing or input lag that being said
integrated graphics have come a long way
over the years and certain cpus are now
capable of running games like cs go and
valorant at over 100 fps in a 1080p
resolution
now if you're a competitive player
you're gonna want a gpu but if you're
just starting out like what do you look
for do you need to sell your kidney to
secure a top of the line graphics card
well you don't want to just stick a 30
90 or 6900 xt in any old computer if the
rest of your components are too old or
can't keep up with your gpu
then that's when you can start to
experience something called
bottlenecking
or so i'm told i don't know what
bottlenecking can you just call them can
you just tell them a bottlenecking is i
don't know and now the guy who actually
knows what he's talking about presented
by amd don't worry dmitry i'll get to it
just to drop some friendly advice off
the top if you're more into the
competitive multiplayer experience
dreaming of going pro and halo infinite
then you don't really need a top of the
line gpu for esports titles your main
focus is smooth gameplay and low latency
but where that gets more complicated is
if you also want to stream and create
content software like obs vmix v tube
studio
and the adobe suite can benefit greatly
from expanded vram and higher core
counts on both your cpu and gpu
especially if you're playing games at
the same time if you're just going to
rock a pre-built pc you don't really
have to worry about this but if you're
going to take your games a little more
seriously and maybe build your own rig
or upgrade individual components then
creating a bottleneck is absolutely
something you'll want to be careful of
obviously a high-end gpu will help
increase your fps as well as the
fidelity of the graphics your pc is able
to pump out but your gpu does all this
working together with all the other
parts in your pc dropping a top of the
line graphics card into your
five-year-old gaming rig isn't going to
make your graphics worse but you will be
leaving most of that card's performance
not to mention a lot of your hard-earned
money on the table creating a bottleneck
and you don't even have to just take my
word for it so in terms of game
performance each is equally important
you always want to buy or build a system
that pairs two that are roughly of equal
capability otherwise you're going to
create what we would call a performance
bottleneck either your cpu is
overpowered or your gpu is overpowered
they really need to be at an equal level
in terms of performance and capability
since your gpu still needs to get
instructions from your cpu access your
ram and other system memory and all of
that communication has to flow through
your motherboard it's far more important
and cost effective to get parts that are
going to work well together and fall
roughly within the same power level
thankfully we have the internet if
you're looking to beef up your pc gaming
experience over the holidays or any
other time of the year then i recommend
doing some research on not just a new
gpu but also all the other parts you
want to put in your new rig or the ones
you already have to make sure you get
the most out of your shiny new tech
sites like pc part picker and the linus
tech tips forums can be an invaluable
resource to those looking for more
detailed pc building information do you
need to know all of your pc components
inside and out to become the next
valorem star
no i can confirm it doesn't make you any
better at games
it will however help you make better
buying decisions when it comes to all of
that fancy hardware that you're fragging
out on and that was the guy who actually
knows what he's talking about presented
by amd now there are some titles that
are gpu bound but thankfully
not in esports the other thing as well
for a lot of esports titles is they
really want to have the widest player
brace they possibly can so you'll see a
lot of games really not trying to push
the envelopes on graphics because they
want you to be able to play that on a
mainstream graphics card integrated
graphics pretty much anything they want
to attract as many players as possible
modern games like gta 5 cyberpunk and
new world need much more heavy lifting
from your graphics card in fact having a
powerful graphics card can massively
improve performance when it comes to
these titles now unless you're an
enthusiast grade single player gamer who
genuinely cares about getting the best
graphics
you don't really need to worry about
getting one of these top of the line
gpus that said you are gonna need
something to help out your cpu gpus have
come a long way they went from rendering
basic 2d images to 3d masterpieces the
technology has steadily progressed over
the past 30 almost 40 years nowadays we
can run our games and programs at
insanely high frame rates at extremely
high resolutions and we can even do this
across multiple displays all of these
are things that the gamers of old could
only dream of there's no doubt that all
of these advancements in gpu technology
have only helped us all enjoy the games
that we love
even more
back in the late 80s dude these [ __ ]
are running dual monitor setups they're
still [ __ ] people i still know people
who don't have dual monitor setups
absolutely
degenerates colton miles that's it miles
miles does not have a dual monitor setup
worked at home for a year and a half
that's what i'm saying homie like come
on there are
monitors in front of me right now
they're five
five that's height well i also have like
three computers on my desk so i mean
come on yeah get your [ __ ] up get your
head out of your ass get your head out
of your ass